major new developments in the just a
small investigation
Chicago police have announced Smollett
is officially a suspect in a criminal
investigation for filing a false report
good meanwhile stunning new surveillance
video obtained by CBS Chicago has
surfaced reportedly showing two brothers
at the center of the case buying what is
believed to be a red hat and ski masks
the day before the attack
this is prosecutors in Chicago we're
meeting with small its lawyers Mike
Tobin outside Criminal Court in Chicago
with the latest Mike and this is all
happening very fast and furious you just
mentioned moments ago the chief
communications officer Anthony Guglielmo
for the Chicago PD says that Jesse
Smollett is now a suspect for a class 4
felony falsifying a police report we
know that's a punishable by a maximum of
three years this while we have just
learned from people who have been
staking out the grand jury room on the
4th floor that the Austin Dario brothers
have gone back inside for round two
inside the grand jury room seem to be
kind of a false start with a grand jury
yesterday and again the people who have
been staking out the grand jury room
says the brothers are inside at this
moment as the case moves moves forward
on a day when we now have surveillance
video coming to us from a WBBM channel
to here in Chicago and this is a
security video from what we're told by
employees of the crafty beaver is inside
of their store and it shows these
individuals buying things like ski masks
what looks to be a Red Hat we know of
the inventory that was taken from the
apartment where the Sandero brothers
were staying here in Chicago one of the
items on that inventory is a Red Hat and
that could have very well played a role
in what is now shaping up more and more
to have been a hoax attack in this case
so we now have Jesse Smollett has been
listed as a suspect in this case
officially according to the chief
communications officer this longstanding
request for police to have a
conversation with Smollett that has not
been realized he never showed up for
this follow-up interview we have some
information that lawyers for Smollett
and police met today the sun-times has
indicated that that meeting is going on
right now the clarification we have
through the official police channels is
that
meeting happened this morning but never
the conversation that they want to have
with Smollett Jesse thanks a lot Mike
all right Emily I believe the
prosecutors have to go hard on this
class for felony they have to prosecute
him they can't just drop this because if
they don't go hard on him it's gonna
send a message that you can get away
with this stuff and not pay a price yeah
absolutely and you know there's
prosecutorial discretion there in
Illinois they could have pursued it as a
misdemeanor they have the option for
filing a false police report or those
exactly so that that speaks for itself
right there and you know those crimes
are classified as there are crimes
against public justice they it is taken
really seriously because it is there
should absolutely be zero tolerance for
and a strong message sent when people do
this especially in the level of
fabrication that you know we are seeing
allegedly went into this that level of
Pro action and creating this entire
dramatic thing and roping in other
people I mean it's it's yes it
absolutely should should have to our
consequence that's for sure one so I'm
Mike Tobin still with us I think Mike
Mike are you there well maybe not yeah
Oh Mike so Mike as I understand it there
was pressure being put to bring smollett
into the grand jury but today apparently
his lawyers spoke to the Cook County
attorneys and said and they said okay he
doesn't have to come in I wondered what
is he sick that what was what was the
mitigating factor or the occult pretory
factor that would lead cook the Cook
County officials to say he didn't have
to appear before the grand jury cuz I
can do it without him I think there's
much more of a situation where you have
you get this with the legal community
that any good lawyer if he's gonna
insist that he did nothing wrong any
good lawyers going to tell him don't go
in for that meeting because all they're
gonna want to do in the course of that
meeting is catch him in a lie
and all indications are that something
is amiss in this case so I don't know if
it's necessary sculpt or evidence that
that that gets involved in that but when
you had this sudden halt to the process
yesterday and the Cook County State's
Attorney Kim Fox recusing herself you
may have some kind of evidence that was
introduced yesterday and should be noted
that the Tribune is running a report
now saying the reason that she has
suddenly recused herself is because she
got pretty close with the family during
the initial stages when everyone thought
that Jessie Smollett was the victim of a
hate crime thanks Mike
Deena you know what's crazy about this
whole thing at how sociopathic this
guy's small it is if they had arrested
two innocent guys he would have said
yeah these are the guys and he would
have been okay with putting away
innocent men and also this is I have a
question these guys work in television
they were kind of very a very successful
show Empire they obviously probably
watch a lot of TV if I watch a lot of
movies like do they not think for one
second that there's going to be a video
camera where the heart in the hardware
store does that think that there's not
going to be like all of these questions
I just feel like he was willing to put
other people away for something that
also was like very poorly done yeah
as for as far as far as a hoax goes he
must have just truly believed that the
media was just going to believe every
word that he said and then he was going
to be protected from that but I'm glad
the police are pursuing it I think it's
good great act or a terrible criminal
yeah you know I don't I don't see how
what he did is not considered a hate
crime because it actually is would have
would have hurt a group of people and to
your point Trump support and yeah bear
with me walk bear with me I listen to
you this this is a hate crime and to
your point that's despicable that he
would have let two people go to jail he
should go away for twenty twenty minimum
twenty years and I think you know people
accuse people like me of dunking on the
libs over this no what you're seeing is
vindication remember us the great the
people that aren't liberals are
vindicated because any kind of
tangential link to Trump you if you
don't believe this story then you're
part of the problem
this this everybody should be pleased
that a hate crime didn't happen because
it means we're less racist than the
media wants us to be and and I don't
care about small it anymore
he's dirt i I'm more pissed off at to
how the media
did this and they got to pay a price
well I'm glad to know it's all about you
no really no no you miss my point one
that's usual that's usual for you
yesterday I think this guy is mentally
ill that's his excuse he's nuts so if
you want him to politicize though it's a
political thing and it vindicates the
trumpet aside he did this on purpose he
had been we didn't even talk about the
magazine with the claw at the letter
with the crushed aspirin
that's a terrorist ego right that's
right that's it is that what he's being
charged
no because I think the FBI is looking
into that as a terrorist express he put
him away for a long time should be
pursued for all of it especially that
terroristic threat as we were talking
about before there's no such thing as
joking or a hoax when it comes to that
that's 100 percent every single threat
is taken seriously by law enforcement as
there was at the time when a hazmat team
was deployed etc also when you said you
know he may be mentally ill I'm not
gonna speak to that but to the fact that
he has a prior from 2007 in California
for false impersonation a DUI and
driving without a valid license when
when he was pulled over for driving
under the influence he said he was his
brother and faked that so this is not
really to let his brother go this guy
not a good older brother either